who you gonna call hi i'm ray parker jr.  writer and performer of the Academy  award-nominated  his single Ghostbusters from the major  motion picture ghostbusters  but that's just one song I've written so  many other major motion pictures theme  songs and submitted them throughout the  years now they're available and together  for one specially priced compilation  [Music]  [Music]  legal yeah these songs have only been  heard by the highest level of Industry  decision makers but now you can feel  like a Hollywood executive in your own  [Music]  [Music]  now there's a whole lotta kinky that  that room is stinky fifty shades of gray  all right  [Music]  there's one thing I know is that  persistence makes perfection so how they  were missed out what that doesn't mean  you have to down basement  what's going on it's a there's a kid and  the Nazi down there order now to receive  your FREE copy of Bobby sings the tubes  theme songs to sequels that were never  made  you